the federal judge is temporarily
blocking a gun rights organization from
publishing blueprints for 3D printed
guns a group of eight Democratic State
Attorneys General sued to stop
texas-based defense distributed after it
uploaded designs for untraceable plastic
Firearms the company had legally
published the blueprints last Friday
after reaching a settlement with the U.S
government in an interview only on CBS
This Morning Tony decouple met the
founder of Defense distributed to found
out why he's fighting to distribute
potentially dangerous information Tony
joins us now this is quite a story what
a story he's quite an individual for
Cody Wilson this is all very very simple
he believes that everyone in America has
a right to build their own Gun Arsenal
at home in 2013 he built the world's
first working plastic firearm and now
he's fighting to publish gun designs
online including AR-15 style rifles and
handguns so everyone else can build them
on their own now we spoke to Wilson
hours before that judge's ruling came
down but he was clear without us he
believes he's already won
I believe that I am championing the
second amendment in the 21st century I
look at the NRA I think it's good for
the safety of Americans you think that's
good for American families you think
that's good for American streets you
think that's good for America yeah I
think unquestionably it's good for the
Future unquestionable walk me through
that I think access to the firearm is a
fundamental human dignity it's a
fundamental human right Cody Wilson's
dream of a downloadable library of gun
Blueprints and a world where anyone can
easily manufacture a deadly weapon at
home stalled Tuesday
a Seattle judge blocked Wilson from
publishing new gun files
and questioned whether the Trump
Administration should have granted his
company permission in the first place
makes no damn sense no damn sense at all
to make those available Washington
State's Bob Ferguson who led the lawsuit
by eight Attorneys General argued that
3D printed plastic weapons are dangerous
because they're untraceable often
undetectable and require no background
check what I'm doing is legally
protected I will go to the Appellate
level I will go to Supreme Court I will
waste all my time Wilson already
published 10 blueprints as of last
Friday and the AR-15 schematics alone
have been downloaded thousands of times
there is nothing good that can come
with defense distributed uploading these
files Poe Murray is chairwoman of
Newtown action Alliance a gun control
group created after the massacre at
Sandy Hook Elementary it's a dangerous
slippery slope into our future and our
laws and our policies have to keep up
with the changing advancements in
technology the future is simply digital
fabrication Wilson argues that it's
already impossible to police 3D gun
technology and he believes he has a free
speech right to publish the designs I'm
talking about files I'm not talking
about the guns I'm not a licensed gun
manufacturer I don't make guns at this
location I have data I can share the
data when somebody downloads a gun from
your website with your blueprints
and kill somebody with it how are you
going to feel personally
I don't believe that I provided you
anything other than the general
knowledge of what an AR-15 is but to
fund his legal fight Wilson's company
does sell these Milling machines they
come pre-loaded with design files that
allow anyone to make their own AR-15 or
1911 handgun in about two days no serial
number and no screening they retail for
two thousand dollars and there's a three
month backlog defense distributed is
still winning this legal battle to be
clear Andy Greenberg is when Wired
Magazine and has followed Wilson since
2013. he says in the long run Tuesday's
ruling is insignificant compared to the
agreement Wilson already reached with
the federal government defense
distributed now has the ability to post
whatever files they want and no one has
successfully been able to stop them
permanently from doing that what makes
you comfortable with the world where
people can pump out guns in their garage
anytime they want to what's going to
make me comfortable is when people stop
coming in this office and acting like
there's a debate about the debate is
over the guns are downloadable the files
are in the public domain and you cannot
take them back you can adjust your
politics to this reality you will not
ask me to adjust mine
now Cody Wilson says he does follow all
required laws and regulations and even
screens people who are looking to buy
his Milling machines under the court
order he can't publish any new
blueprints until September at the
earliest now I think the big news here
is that milling machine it is
essentially a shrunken down gun Factory
for your home right the NRA is not
backing him not backing him because he
takes the files and pumps them out at
home no need to go to a gun shop no need
to pay a company no gun gun
manufacturers don't benefit from Milling
machines at people's homes he has a
tombstone outside of his office just to
be very clear about what his mission is
and on that Tombstone it says American
gun control wow Tony thanks